okay yes yes yes there we go all right
there we go all right all right the
custom story is the crus that's the gun
the crews of Brewer Manor they took a
manner and then they put it on the ocean
they tried to cruise it but it was
doomed from the start because it just
started sinking and all the inhabitants
are like this is a really bad idea and
then they died good story huh all right
the year is 1856 my name is Anthony Bell
ham and I am a homicide detective in
Scotland Yard a I've hey hey okay all
right here we go
my name is Anthony Bell MA and I am
almost died detective in Scotland Yard a
how a boot I've been sent to investigate
mysterious disappearances of Andrew
Brewer and Brewer mana ain't the word
Brewer that's just a little it when you
see it you just bird Andrew bird Berman
deep in the heartland of Inge ping the
heartland of Canada England a all I okay
are here we go this stream is off to a
roaring start
such quality so much wow so Sheba hmm
much covers a mixing English Scott and
Canadian a I'm mixing all these
different variables a oh no I want to go
home
door lock by itself okay go out anymore
oh no no no oh there's a lantern I need
to find Andrew brew long as I find
anywhere things are gonna be okay
all right the comments are like over
there I really wish they were over here
hang on I need to fix that wait hang on
I can't read the comments good I'm good
hang on turning slow mode on gotta
happen sorry gang got to happen just the
way be any comments like closer okay
there we go
that just means okay much love you want
another kiss before we get going
this kiss for good luck yeah I'll do it
I'll do it if you want me to you want to
kiss do you wanna you want to kiss I see
some yeses mmm-hmm
get ready let's go to me good here we go
ah that was a good one those are the
best ones okay no just gonna put this
home place feel like a damn it
okay no all right so ended amnesia yeah
if you watch my if you watch my Let's
Plays and haven't watched my live
streams you know that they're you you
don't know that how much different they
are from my let's place my live streams
are less total bull even if I'm playing
like something I'm supposed to take
seriously like amnesia ah don't want to
do it I don't want to do it as if dad
who'd do that but anyway more people are
streaming in remember you only got a day
left to buy a shirt if you wanted buy a
shirt for the charity thing where all
the profits go to the cherry you got
doing now or else you'll never have a
chance and that glasses t-shirt is
probably going away forever
what do that is the blood trail wonder
where it leads
well I don't have to wonder very far
because it goes right to here hmm well
well who is that luckily it's not Andrew
what talking like jontron today it has
passed two full moons since I found that
place in this strange curiosity towards
the place that has just escalated to the
place where I can't stand this place
much longer I just need to find a place
out
once and for all what is in that place I
will wait a month no matter how bad this
place curiosity gets please okay all
right got bread hang on I think I get
this yep
ah damn it two points yeah [ __ ]
what I think I get it ah come on I was
robbed
ah damn it
hang on everybody shut up this is way
more important than what I'm doing yeah
God never mind I'm done all right
this is I have to find a storage key or
use it long Jeff damn it
good man lost all my skills tinderboxes
I've been wasting my lamb which way I
got plenty
yeah so much confusion yeah so if you're
joining me now thanks well remember this
is a secret life thing no one's supposed
to know about this hmm
everybody [ __ ] whoa hi are you a pooper
your elbow beretta huh boof
I knew it call that one from a mile away
I know my boobers puffers whatever I
called him I forgotten what I called him
I've no idea poof it's a pooper okay I
bet the next one ain't gonna be no
[ __ ] ain't gonna be no pooper come
scare no hold up here all right
things look good so far I got another
wait a minute what's going on there you
guys see that you guys see what ah ah
bedroom key no I need the storage key
earth block pew yeah pilfer you can
compute for I'm not gonna be
live-streaming very long today either
guys I'm not gonna be doing it very hard
or long did I mention it's hard no I
mean not hard this one what what am I
talking about I know
anyway you can still no you cannot buy
the marklar 0t tomorrow both t-shirts
will stop sailing at midnight tonight
this is your last day so if you're
trying to put it off you ain't gonna get
nothing because unfortunate I was
explaining this before yeah where the
sales department works they need all the
sales in a week before the end of the
month because that's when they send the
money to me and in order for me to get
the donations in for November 2nd I need
them in by this the end of this month so
they needed a week before so the sales
gotta cut off at midnight tonight
because a week from tomorrow is the end
of the month that's what it's all about
so that's why you cannot buy one
tomorrow you gotta buy today this why
this live stream is here to raise
awareness that you're gonna miss out if
you don't get it you're gonna miss out
so you better buy now click the link
down there there's a my face says buy
shirts click that it is it it do it is
what it do want you approver yeah I know
it how did I know that oh wait
because it always happens bedroom the
door is open well you didn't even do a
couch Inc
I guess words are just as good as
extinct something doesn't seem right
here it's a bedroom but there ain't no
hot lady in this bed Mousavi squeeze in
my room you know what I mean right ma'am
okay everybody shut up little energetic
today little energetic today 4th of May
1856 last night I went to the kitchen
stores to kiss on the eat couldn't sleep
I lifted the sack from the ground to my
balls are so big I discovered a hatch
which led me underneath the manor I went
down and I saw a door leading to even
more people so deep then I went down
through adorns governing network at
tunnels
it's hard to creep sound someone was
screaming deeding the tunnels I want no
further I believe that's the strange
feeling start from there because it has
been with me since is this Breuer
this is Breuer is this is this David
blue I think this is David blue
because I'm in Brewer Manor the biggest
bedroom I think this Dave group I'm a
little energetic I'm a little energetic
I've never just I haven't I haven't
live-streamed for fun in a while
no it's like the first chance I've had
yeah at the master bedroom David thank
you I actually love playing this for fun
like a game for this for fun because you
know everyone knows that I played
amnesia a lot I don't need to take it
seriously anymore so I could just have
fun with it whereas my let's plays on my
thing on my thing also knows as YouTube
is we let me just live my sax I I am
more serious because I want to treat it
with more respectful for this I just
went yeah wait wait
yeah dicks yeah balls hey can I open it
ah
what why temperamental [ __ ] all right
here we go hey Deb
Barrett okay so now quest secret place
can we lead it what but a quest I get a
quest I don't have a quest wait very -
when I get diary - what oh did I get
that first ever I get that first what
soul Ambrym the stole am room in the
bottom of brew manor
I don't know what's going on here but I
don't like it I don't like it why are
there so many people here ask so rift
well I don't know it's a secret live
dream rule number one about my live
streams you don't frickin talk about my
live streams to anyone some of you guys
so you guys tell anyone did anyone of
you tell anyone about this live stream
because it's des right up there
this is a secret live stream no one's
supposed to know about it and yet I see
thousands of people in here what kind of
place this is oh I don't know maybe a
tunnel bull you get to the bottom of
this mystery
hi Johnny 102 but the only one with it
the only one I'm gonna say hi to anyone
no should i what should I say Oh
God he was a [ __ ] who's behind the
door man to be a [ __ ] I'm talking to
God here for a moment why could you made
this game I don't don't even know
anymore why did that need to be a [ __ ]
who's behind us when I talk to you up
there I'm on the top floor my oh hello
hey what on earth are they doing it they
I'm not just gonna talk about him like
he's not like hey hey man we what's
doing on this is this guy's just
exercising right here he's just like hey
you might spot me for a bit I'm a little
scrawny you need to build some muscle
boom I'm like no no thank you
we're gonna go now got fun no wait spot
me bro no ah that's not a pooper that's
probably really that's probably real
I've seen a few of these things before I
know that probably real okay oh talking
to see I out there okay even though God
dingus
got ding I see you in there Oh - you're
dead I didn't even know as I was a
headless version week hey hey oh oh oh
gosh oh he doesn't have a head oh don't
this duster doors locked I need a key
Wow bloop bloop er in like Lane turn
yeah I'm playing a custom story this is
the curse of brew Manor
hello hello oh God 10th of August my
name is Andrew Peru and because this
probably is the last layer on my life
will tell you about this curse I will
start by saying that I finally solved
this mystery but I will pay the ultimate
sacrifice for it I never want things to
go this far but I had no choice because
my investigation went no further than
the manor I was going to quit my
investigation but I'm an investigator
alright in Friday I sent a letter to
Scotland Yard and said that I need help
in here I don't know if they send anyone
to check but would I was there to check
whoo all I can do is hope that someone
will come then what I was supposed to go
then in Saturday evening 5th of August
minus 6 p.m.
dinner could you be more specific I
didn't even do anything
what happened why that back here even do
anything huh with several landlords in
the dining room I feel really dizzy stru
struggling to get up from the table then
all of a sudden went all went black I'll
want black and the last thing I heard
once you want black go back and last
thing I heard mr. Albert talking of
something happening tonight in Seoul
Ambrym is where I do I'm in the zoo
Ambrym then I woke up in the middle of
the corridor and realized it I've been
dragged up this long stairs and then
thrown in this large room where I write
this large letter my fortune I can say
that I am really comfortable in here
compared to the other prisoners that are
here some of them have already went
through the Roth trot holes to Remini
and they have turned into something that
shouldn't even exist some of them have
not fully turning they're kept in those
prison cells the one who is responsible
for oh my god nightmarish his landlord
landlord you know yeah keep talking to
my landlord
I mean Lord of the land Sir Albert
Cunningham of York Shire the other said
I know are involved are Sir Robert McKee
almond of Scotland and Sir David quartz
of Nottingham the Brousseau manor of
Wales and Michael Constantine the right
hand of Her Majesty I owe this letter
will somebody help bring justice to
these traitors goodbye bye Oh bye how we
go on dear soonish alright but this
guy's probably dead don't care no large
oil yeah secret no strange yeah ah yeah
this is obviously like I said before
this isn't like a top rated one
it's kind of just like a Miss story
though I miss them they all happen oh I
didn't check these pass right yeah it's
right there we go got a key to this
lamrim let's go to the salon broom hey
let's see what's going on over here
what's going on over Hey
oh yeah this doors locked that's right
go to this tool Ambrym what this
foodless lamb broom Wow
Matt oh there's someone she's gone here
ah I can't wait what's going on I can't
fit oh bloody hell
that is and burn oh yeah perfect ending
yeah oh the rain whoa all right oh god I
can't believe it ah it's like
masterpiece cool oh yeah God did you
guys see that coming
ha sure did man that was good whoa all
right damn house great
ahh 10/10 game of the year can't even
believe it I didn't even see the twist
coming when Andrew Berg fly on a slab
like oh good he's killing me and I was
like boom hey what's going on about a
boot time I solve this mystery a and
just then Oh guys good eyes good best
story of all time
gosh storytelling was incredible the end
ah almost goes it ending to that letter
ah that's good ok dad
whoa all right well after that emotional
roller coaster I don't even know how to
top it well I think I just got in this
large room nope
gonna play another one I'm gonna play
another one
I got another bad one my oh my whole
list my whole list is just bad ones and
there's so much fun okay I'm gonna play
I'm gonna play the game I'm gonna um I'm
gonna play the game I'm gonna play the
game which you all just lost want to
play a game turn off the lights put on
your headphones and get ready because
when you press that start button a new
world will emerge let's play would I do
let voice the game oh oh
I don't think I can handle this that's
actually good art that's likely well
done I don't think I can handle this
guy's I don't think here we go I broke
in a strange room I felt like I
recognized it somehow and that feeling
that every little shadow was crawling
closer to me it was something I couldn't
shake ha ha yeah you all lost the game
ok here we are
I have anything no oh here it is
hello stranger I'm guessing you're
wondering 1 you're here you actually use
the property soon you will find out
until then I suggest you look around who
knows maybe you will find something
useful as you see I'm giving you a
lantern some oil and a few tinderboxes
use them well you don't want to end up
losing yourself in the darkness
oh I'm sorry I didn't introduce myself
my name is well I don't really have a
name most people just call me the
darkness but in the other hand those
people never made it very far so let's
see how you will do let's play the game
yeah I thought that would have like
maniacal laughter after that it seemed
it seemed like something that would have
maniacal laughter up to it man it's
really dark in here where these tender
boxes he was oh oh oh I see
fiend of black could get to Black's is
Jimmy
oil Gina Black's is all right there we
go
all right I'm good what hello
oh the other it's a pole I thought it
was a push oh you bastard yeah I do that
Oh No who the hell's in there it's all
foggy
ok
yeah you don't care don't care
no it's tinderbox and rocks here's me
alright
those rocks are moving okay anyway so
back to I really wish I was back in
Brewer Manor so let's begin the game
isn't complicated at all just think of
it as hide-and-seek you're hiding and
I'm see I guess we could call it that
you'll find out what I mean was seeking
soon enough why Steve do you mean
murdering oh I forget to tell you the
rules it isn't really hard just stay
alive and that painting in the next
hallway it always felt like it see right
through it Oh she'll again hi where's my
trial like it's cheering I feel like
you're just G right through it
okay Wow God Steve look I found another
key maybe it leads to the strange door
in the first hallway I can give you one
chance to quit the game do not go in
there there will be no return but if you
want to continue find your way in there
well it's so nice of him wait how many
keys he said I found another key but I
only found the one good night crash I
figure oh wow what and raddest whoa add
up all ate it up turn it up I need
someone else is throwing it weight Halen
was it demon wall right here I'm just
gonna what that's Dana what I doing it
yeah I can't get it anymore oh no Billy
no well what are you doing oh hey back
up and you're so gonna begin again yeah
please go he's gone I broke the game I
broke game Oh No
I bet I'm gonna come round this corner
and pick see all the stuff like here
can't use this item we talking about oh
maybe I actually got to use it only
these
okay whoop oh here we go
where'd you go hurry up oh here you go
it was gonna be here did not here he's
not here he's not here let us call it
helping you that's what I'm doing at
least that's what you will think I am
doing I don't think you're doing that oh
no oh no oh no like oh it's gone oh it's
okay all right then fine was I supposed
to hide oh oh what I did was not hide oh
um dumb okay so I got another key do we
know yeah what up over here whoa hey
wait a minute
ah land my land I'm awesome thanks so
much everybody thanks for being you
remember we're here to sell shirts
because they won't be available after
today they will be gone forever at
midnight tonight is the last day is why
I'm life doing in this secret livestream
that you were supposed to tell no one
about the Lord Remus secret everybody
yeah please everybody
gosh life seems today oh I see
let me use this key that I have on this
door well I got a pretty lling about
this guy's the strange stairway led to a
long corridor the lights were fading and
still those shadows were coming after me
I got a bad feeling about this
Oh No well I got a bad feeling about
these footprints
oh no they lead to this door well I got
a bad feeling
let's see what's over here another key
oh I got a bad feeling about that sound
oh it's actually sex is bad cuz on that
key look very useful stranger maybe you
should pick it up do not fear though I
wouldn't hurt you yet does I mean you're
a poof er no wait hang on
odd you're a pool for ain'tcha Oh No
Oh got a bad feeling about this one oh
no oh no oh no oh no that's always the
pooper oh he's a pooper oh no oh now
poof oh well oh God
whatever oh wait what good I know to
scribble something down about that just
luck may be fun to be unlocking huh well
it'd have to be pretty delicate like
this drop no but no oh and if you don't
have enough money for this shirt but
you'd still like to help um you can
always go straight to the extra life
fundraising page which is also there
under the cartoon version of mice my
face and you can donate directly I think
you can donate whatever you'd like you
may but this is with it sorry sneezed
I'm destroyed all your [ __ ] whatever you
don't care right open up
yeah we go click click click click click
click and monster Oh thought there was
gonna be more yeah all the things are
down there also this is gonna be on
YouTube probably maybe um I don't know
what I'm doing
you YouTube who cares about that
YouTube's dying anyway knowing no one
cares no one cares there we go oh I'm
not gonna question the questionable
housing design of whatever the hell this
is but why I never mind I'm not gonna
question it hello
how about you oh how about you up off
good day that way yeah that way forever
in down
I'm also not oh there's something under
this gas then finally I'm also not gonna
question oh this and that
and oh well I'm no game design expert
what's jum judge zoom right here huh
also that there's very strange boy uh
not gonna question that not gonna
question oh yeah this is a very secret
life in Shh chicken fruit just this is a
secret
this is generalizing but if yes why I've
been watching way too much grain grubs
but lately I love the game grumps by the
way of absolute love the funniest guys
I've been watching way too much ah got
it like non-stop it's like my new TV
show that I watched can't stop myself
from quoting them ah my guru but ok I
see you all made it all the way here
that's impressing ah that's impressing
actually from now on things will be more
become more serious oh really
no more playing around you will notice
that I mean soon enough but as a
survivor in the game your minds back
designed the darkness I thought other
people called you the darkness but not
you
yeah well whatever whatever the dark my
what might watch the darkness yeah
anyway unlocks the kitchen Oh is the
kitchen on the second floor because that
would make sense
also I love how these doors are labeled
so I'm informed oh this is the cup
oh wait no oh oh oh oh the engineering
me loves this this side is somehow made
of stone but Oh wood and drywall stone
wood and drywall wooden wallpaper stone
okay la la la la la la la la la kicking
all your [ __ ] all over the place la la
la okay also this isn't so much a
kitchen as like a big empty room okay I
am a house critic hey engineer here it's
gotta be you no stop bill I used to
build decks I built deck for like two
years i'm i'm basically a carpenter so i
mean come on it's not really not really
anything what good are you
I'm having a seizure the floor is moving
on me okay ah the footprints go over
this way what I'm gonna go over this way
oh boy I picked the right room yeah yeah
yeah okay all right anyway uh you all
close your eyes for that right I meant
to tell you to close your eyes and not
look but uh yeah you shouldn't have seen
that hopefully no one will watch this
when I put it up on you too hopefully no
one watches this oh boy
look at my own selection look at tours
oohs hey was a leg doing oh I get it
Oh storming at orso's are you gonna nice
leg here some arms and hands with the
fingers they never come with the fingers
like ah was his hand doing here god I
hate it when cans getting my legs yeah
uh-oh did it really really just go read
out there oh look a crowbar in the
kitchen of always huh
well how peculiar oh hi boy everybody
has good would you like a doozy tours oh
oh
select haha Silent Hill fan 21 9 9 7
that's a good job
finger-licking good very funny but judge
me oh you didn't like it opinion ow owie
they actually kind of hurt so uh yeah
bout that can these guys go downstairs
don't think they can oh what's that oh
oh what's it oh what'd you say them to
me what what's wrong
ruff oh you miss oh what's gonna what
huh what's going what huh you stayin sir
Vick you're a douche ah don't be so hard
on yourself oh come on man you're not
that bad Oh turn around oh okay I'm
gonna do this way smack glug all better
now
ah what oh no I went into the kitchen to
get a crowbar to break out of the
kitchen I just went in alright alright
alright oh yeah oh yeah I love this well
I'm loving this did it break oh that's
fantastic
oh it's so great that it broke and even
need that for anything else
Oh wonderful wonderful oh look the door
is magically open
ah I was wondering like maybe if it
would be like I need that crowbar to
also break open another door but nope
no but not really not really I mean that
would be that would be step silly it's
silly I don't even have it anymore it's
not even in my inventory it's gone it's
just obliterated completely yeah no key
no nothing no nothin it would have how
about this other door that mysteriously
probably became unlocked ah crap it's
actually locked maybe there was a key up
there that I needed but I have no idea I
have no idea
oh okay the door took me to some kind of
machinery still not being able to avoid
the feeling of being watched I notice
how it got darker and darker the deeper
I got into the game did it did you
really oh I'm so sorry then your sisters
at the Children's Hospital thought no
Finn um we are raising money for um the
Cincinnati Children's Hospital again
this time because Oh
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry mr. door did I
get in your way
hang on let me say something we are
raising money for the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital again because the
extra life thing it does for local
charities so um if you're if you're
donating straight to it um it goes to
the Cincinnati Children's Hospital
that's why it's good all right don't
anyway yay don't be rude don't be rude
as you can see I'm writing this with my
own blood I actually didn't see that
every single part of me hurts and the
crucial headache is killing me I can't
take the pressure anymore
kill me I've been dirt enough the
darkness have put me up to so much I
don't want to continue I'm going mad get
inside the room locked with a huge
padlock is inaccessible unaccepted
unaccessible there is no key to it I
also found two objects that were
emerging creepy atmosphere I didn't dare
keep them I hid them in here in the
machinery I don't want any contact with
them I think one of the objects were a
hammer that's all I remember
oh this hammer oh it's all dark I don't
want to touch it yeah now I'm giving up
the dark just broke me down he tore me
and shredded all my oh I'm a broken man
farewell
Oh world really really really really
really okay
farewell this guy couldn't think that
look on a hammer there's this lock here
show myself that's what he did that's
pretty much that's the lethal logic
people making this game what oh well ah
doors lock strange okay thing Thing
Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing
Thing okay this is where the padlock in
I need to go find the hammer so that I
can swung in it oh oh hello mr. Roche is
where did he hide this thing where did
this dick hide this thing weird this big
hug Hamar oh well this hammer doesn't
feel very bad I've got a good grip to it
actually
mr ah I gotta also find something else
that means there's gotta be there's
gotta be like a pic or uh thingy or a
railroad tie or something that I can
pick with anything anything anything
anything anything anything anything
anything anything anything anything
yeah anything nope nope nope nope no no
no nope okay how about nope just as good
as yes I guess fine whatever
hello what the hell what the hell what
is going on here
no I do not do shoutout stop asking
follows Tufano is it every time I do
every time I do uh well let's play Vayne
is really you blast right by stefano
half the time I don't see him when you
guys tell me to and yeah yeah yeah the
fun as beautifies saying it's not my
thing
no I think Peter buys a great guy by the
way I actually talked to beauty by you
know
cool guy Aaron bad-mouthing for the
robberies okay anyway but enough of that
BAM [ __ ] yeah okay I don't know what to
do I need to find her
I need to find a thing but I can't find
a thing ah I'm out of oil - gonna rent
it of oil seems like these oils don't
fill it up as much as it usually did
what's going on I can't find a thing
maybe's out of here get back huh yeah do
more problems in the future I usually
don't go out of my way to ask for
provinces usually people just add me
like a little proper little problem
that's how it usually goes but right now
I don't care about that all I want to do
fine with a friggin pic is where this
guy is it he in the note did he say do
you say didn't care hit them here in the
machinery I don't want to contact with
him when it was a hammer where did you
hide that what do I hide it where did
you hide it and I'd like to comment it's
not the machine room or anything like
that it's the machinery I hit it into
machinery I did looked under everything
over everything in everything things
good hello no I am Todd I'm talking like
that ah yeah ah I don't know I don't
know no you find it I in the fire I
behind the fire is anyone see it has
anyone seen it
have I missed it on the table people
what table I don't
ah you find it it's not here it's not
here
you'd be like on top of something you'd
be like up if I think if I get on
something big like I can get on there I
could see it huh
maybe maybe let me try that that might
just be stupid enough to be something
that he would do we try that we shut up
I didn't I touched every box I've
touched every one of them I didn't miss
a single box I got all the boxes it's
just not high enough this is supposed to
be a secret guys God there's almost 4000
people in here this is supposed to be a
secret livestream guys you ruin
everything if I ruin everything I mean
you help a great cause
God why you gotta be such awesome people
that donate so much money to charity
yeah really gets on my nerves how
awesome you guys are I wish I could be
half as off as immense as you are I
can't even talk you're so great
God you people rock mmm get to my nerves
how great you are
okay what about this can I use this oh
this I stuff this in there oh this here
I would think that it would be glowing
find it Stephano okay don't know don't
know I don't know I don't know
this closet do I go this closet will be
there yeah run out of oil
yeah yeah no-one's seen it right no one
has seen this strange object no one has
seen it it's not like it's not like I've
overlooked it and you guys are all like
oh no you guys are like oh shovel by the
wall maybe I don't know I can't even see
anymore
oh maybe oh maybe oh maybe I don't think
this game maker put this much thought
into it but oh oh get wonk wonk wonk
wonk wonk nope any dad ain't it ain't it
Annie
oh I thought I thought I saw a shiny
thing goes wrong GM it guys in the
[ __ ] ah fine
okay fine whatever you know what I've
lost the game you dick whoever is oh I
can't even go out I can't go out it
won't even let me go back yeah
ball thick Oh
thick oh I can't move the gears on the
table and besides I'll be able to see
through them anyway um let me just move
all the boxes again is in case got
tossed under one of them see it yeah I'm
bleeding bloody [ __ ] yeah
not here yeah
yeah yes I am aah oh yeah that's what
you get
but will you deserve ah what the hell
what the hell how did I miss that
yeah yeah god damn it damn it damn it
that was so easy to him I'm such a
friggin idiot God looking everywhere
except the obviously the game does act
like I'll hide it in a bucket Oh
everyone will be able to find it look
back the pit okay yeah okay
so I got that what's the point of that
to get a key unlock the prison cells
really I'm gonna see someone like oh you
won't spot me oh you're back you won't
spot me this time
hmm no oh okay well bye then all right I
can't get out ah wait a minute no oh
wait there's a door over there that's
right I just got to go deeper I can't
even go back
Oh unlock the door and run what's gonna
happen if we do what could happen I'm
gonna key oh no oh no
kliklak gun oh well darkness in the
prison seems strange and in some ways
even unnatural as I slowly pay temel all
what you guys read that I guess that's
all that matters it's all that matters
you guys did it good for you cuz you're
all awesome
Kesler the best guy you guys are so
great I wish I could be half as cool as
any of you but I'm not ha doesn't seem
right huh oh here we go I need some oil
I can't see a damn thing I can't see a
damn thing
Jubei part me I can't see a damn thing I
can't see anything you see anything you
know
Eugenie hello Blanc no nothing anything
in this bucket
watching you watching you bucket
watching you from now on bucket here no
change there's nothing in the other room
Jeter is just oh no oh that was mildly
ow hey why Steve made it all the way
here
this key is leading to the final
corridor which will take you to the end
of the first part of the game make your
way there and see what I made for you
okay hey buddy you look pretty good in
that lighting like [ __ ]
it looks good looks good in red I like
that very great Menace very minute where
do I go for this final corridor
boy Joe wish I could see [ __ ] that would
be nice ow oh okay whatever let him do
my Christopher Walken okay hey
amnesia monsters run why I don't know
what to do with AB Christopher Walken ah
Christopher Walken was the deal with
airline food cow Christopher Walken now
down done BAM
yeah alright got it whoa got it okay
did it yeah let's go to one right that's
good one
what is this the final hallway no good
didn't want to be anywhere
that's not even open a bowl so is that
uh that a good Christopher Walken
everybody did a good good gabagool where
do I go what are we doing I know where
to go final corridor my ass hell do I go
you know that door was locked but it
didn't go anywhere
what are they talking about oh it was
the other one that looked just like all
the other ones oh I could see how anyone
would make that mistake oh oh okay I
thought that I was wrong what a dead end
oh oh yeah oh no it sounded like I'm
just gonna fall down
oh no oh no no no no oh yeah boom did it
yeah all right whoo yeah BAM
whoa dead all right
get good did it crane so good all right
good job
another good one dead end guys dead
Nemus copyrighted music gotta get out of
there gotta get out of it cap get out of
there gotta get up gotta get gone there
we go okay so haha I know these are the
worst
I picked the bad ones I picked the bad
ones the ones that were bad
I picked close they were bad so I'm
gonna do I'm getting raspy what do you
mean I'm getting raspy this one might
bring some wool you want to see me drink
all this you asked for this
yeah yeah yeah
oh my puke on camera I'm gonna be very
upset yeah yeah those old water now that
one had been sitting there for a while
yeah yeah that's pure vodka go to do
food whoo go dirty
yeah okay I'm not dead all right so
we're gonna do one more I don't have a
lot of time today obviously it's a
weekday and people get stuff cool we're
gonna play oh you guys got a choice I
got three on my list I got the
interrogation chapter one
David's nightmare I kind of will play
that one oh and the secret basement hey
let me read all the let me read all the
BIOS oh god not that one oh good god no
absolutely not
how about David's nightmare you are
David Oh genius a man in his mid-30s
moved into grossen burger small state
everything seemed pleasant enough until
you started having nightmares
this time Oh everyone wants David
nightmare wait hang on limit let me in
all fairness let me read the secret
basement because if it's like an uncle
Larry's basement it's gonna be horrible
okay the year is 1753 you wake up in the
storage room of your dad's huge mountain
mansion not remembering what happened
the only thing you can remember is that
you started questioning your dad about
what he's doing all the time now you're
determined nice ounds like [ __ ] sounds
like [ __ ] suck my shot
we're gonna go to David's nightmare yeah
David's nightmare yeah yeah yeah Emmet
Robert presents another custom story for
amnesia
David's nightmare
I like that intro it was like succour
well oh yeah
is that custom music I hear maybe not
maybe it is good stuff good stuff so far
I'm actually gonna conserve my or
jump-scare ah can open it okay you know
what do I do this alright I guess this
is the end of the game cuz oh oh oh
Ruki oh it's gonna be a good one good
one
huzzah whoa hey you're not here and it's
that picture I hate
we might actually be good ah I like you
I like you
we picked good we picked a good one oh
we picked a good one I might shut up
about the eagle statue I just spit
everywhere
I spent everywhere all over my
microphone it came let's do what who's
screaming hang on what's going on over
here
love it so dear friend oh wait no I need
to I need to open that small chamber
door so I can get the key inside and
unlock that the app spit all over my
microphone guts everywhere ah everywhere
marks roar hey this wasn't open before a
small key to a small door oh this is
actually got one but I'm not gonna take
it seriously or anything I'm just gonna
do it whoa he's that Bart's a dog's head
I didn't even notice that there's a jump
scare coming up you guys know it and I
know it we all know it we know what's
happening
the bragging it's gonna happen oh I
thought something was gonna happen
ah yeah alright whatever
ready for non-stop jump scares can that
be a thing want that to be a thing I
want that to happen
I want it to happen so badly ah love it
love it so moody different got open up
oh oh this hallway looks suspicious
ah piss Cooper okay I shouldn't wanna
try a real one oh good one mm oh cool oh
[ __ ] it's still here
where am I Oh II know man another good
one
whoo all right is he behind me see right
behind me push all right okay all right
it was a good one
the old switcheroo this Twitter lumba ah
ah man this is a good one oh whoa what
the hell something has gone horribly
wrong
my visions all webbley wobbly
little piggy no no that's a wrong game
mrs. damn neva what the goop is gone Wow
the door was being eaten alive this is
so cool it's all unique and stuff and
well done I believe I found a way to
destroy the nightmare this door is the
door to the exit this orb is the door to
the exit and the missing fragments are
the key I need to find them and assemble
this orb then time will tell
alright I need to find the frag I need
to find the fragment it's so cool I
can't see a thing
I don't have any oil left I guess they
go this way oh yeah oh oh well thanks
for that it was just hanging there in
the mid air what's up with that
that's so weird whoa hello
I'll take that a key to the end what
where is it I don't know where it is I
think it tried to swipe at me buddy
mister oh oh did did I get it looks like
another piece Bobby
Oh it'll lit up here oh well this is
actually really good
well that don't look good the channeler
is used to electrify in place magic
inside a special dagger just place it on
the machine and wait for a few moments
once the process is done take the dagger
and then hit the statical rods ah the
ones that are similar to the ones in
this room it will create a disturbance
that will then shut them down find the
dagger somewhere in the room first and
be careful that did what whoa okay I
wish I wasn't so wibbly-wobbly I gotta
find it dagger where is it digger it's
that it was in Oh No that it was in this
room that'll keep don't be right at all
ah that dagger unpowered soul power
I wish I could stop wibbly-wobbly no
object to use it on Ella this poof no
how about this one baboo
did it work yeah there we go I must use
this on the two rods in the room to save
the remaining fragments of my mind got
the power dagger won't get you yeah oh
yeah you have to go to the bathroom
there's no time right now oh wait no I'm
still alive I thought that had that bit
thump yeah need to crawl over to the
other one come on come on I got this ah
it did it maybe what do they did aha
there we go yeah a key to the end this
is the last piece
I think baby and scrap is there any
other piece miss Oh boom ha ha did I
done it did our one do no one
no yes maybe so whoa what the hell what
happened what's going on oh oh oh I can
finally return to reality I did it yeah
shorten Sweden to the point
congratulations player you have
completed David's I'm Barry hope it was
an enjoyable custom story hold on to
your hat and new CS is in development as
you read this goodbye and have a nice
day that was great
no I didn't I don't even care if it was
short that was a great one that was a
great one that was fantastic I love that
one it tricked me it did good scares it
had a good like switcheroo with the
monster it did the door thing that was a
great one artistically it was different
it was stylized I loved it 10 out of 10
cows great